your Trump impression has taken the
nation by your portrayal of Trump and I
I got of course is not from here that's
from here now of course you've been in
this business quite a while New Yorker
you've had a lot of run-ins with Trump
before he became president I mean we all
did we all did but I understand that you
worked with him on a movie he had that
building the old Gulf and Western which
is the Trump International on Columbus
Circle and they renovated it into condos
and made it residential and the two top
penthouses was the whole top floor where
two units that were unsold he kept them
in his pocket whatever and they said to
me do you want to or use the space and
we'll give you a very very favorable
rate and they did it was very kind very
generous I shot a movie there and then
later on he said to me if you want me to
be in the movie let me know here here's
the dates I'm free my office is the
dates I'm free and if you want to put me
in a scene I'll just walk through every
movie I'm in that you have a cameo of me
in the movies a hit home alone you're
always ahead this is I'm the lucky charm
here's my date yeah we get the day Samba
literally like oh we're at the airport
that day too bad oh god we were just
dying to have you but we're locked into
the airport see those two dates that we
just can't do it yeah you know it's we
had I don't know it was like two weeks
ago Chris O'Donnell was here and he said
when he was shooting Scent of a Woman
with Pacino that they were shooting a
scene at the Plaza and he said that they
were told the only way we can shoot at
the Plaza which is owned by Trump is if
we let Trump be in the movie and so they
had to shoot a scene where Trump pulls I
remember this pulls up in a limo and he
gets out with I think Marla at the time
gets out and walks Pat and so they said
they shot it and then the minute they
were done shooting it they just threw
the film away so we think see he shot
more scenes
movies I feel bad because people have
done that with some scenes of me and my
films they've thrown them right in the
garbage yeah yeah yeah no it's in your
memoirs
[Laughter]
you